well breaking news now and the climate
protest group into late britain
has apologized for its disruption called
in recent weeks uh in a statement their
spokesperson liam norton said insulate
britain wishes to profoundly apologize
for the disruption caused over the past
three weeks we cannot imagine
undertaking such actually normal
circumstances but we believe that
reality of our situation has to be faced
uh well joining me now is the
spokesperson for interlake britain tim
goff i mean mr goff
i mean why apologize if you think you
need to apologize for it you just
shouldn't have done it in the first
place should you
yeah that's a good question adam um
well we're apologizing to the ordinary
people in this country for the
destruction that's been caused then
we're not really apologizing to the
politicians because we think uh that
they need to take concrete action just
as we've taken concrete action on the
streets
are you apologizing basically because of
a court judgment rather than
any uh lasting feelings of regret
no nothing to do with the courts at all
no no no we genuinely do not want to
cause disruption to the ordinary people
in this country we feel we have to take
the action because no concrete action in
relation to climate change and
insulating houses of britain is being
taken by the politicians it's not being
taken by boris johnson or the home
secretary or anybody
so we're apologizing to the ordinary
people in this country but we will
continue to take
actions like this until the politicians
also take concrete action to reduce the
co2 output of this country and also to
improve the ordinary lives of people in
this country by insulating their homes
right so so you're apologizing for
something but you're going to carry on
doing it you're going to carry on
blocking the roads is that right
that's correct i believe that there are
some activists who despite the current
injunctions are willing to risk jail and
unlimited fines in order to try to get
across to the politicians the importance
of this issue
but i mean with all due respect i failed
to see what you think you're achieving i
mean obviously you're getting some
publicity uh for your cause but i i
can't believe and we saw a lady
yesterday
who was trying to
deal with her sick mother and was
blocked by you i can't believe
why you feel inconveniencing the public
to this extent in any way
increases
the popularity of your cause
well it's not so much a question of
increasing the popularity it's a
question of bringing it to the attention
of the politicians and making them
understand that unless they take action
then these sorts of inconveniences and
problems will continue
because no action is being taken by them
there's lots of politic
policies being mentioned there's lots of
things that boris is saying but he's not
actually taking leadership and taking
concrete action to reduce the co2 output
of this country right and improve the
ordinary lives of people of this country
i mean i think
you would have to i would dispute
whether politicians are doing nothing
we've got cop 26 coming up we've got
endless fringe meetings speeches about
what they want to do about climate
emergency uh politicians are trying to
deal with it i mean what specifically
are you holding the motorist to ransom
for for the government to do what would
the government do
this week that would make you all buzz
off and find something useful to do
okay so just to address the question of
whether they're doing anything you're at
the conservative party conference
there's lots of talk talk talk going on
we want them to walk the wall
politicians are really great
the concrete action is very very clear
we've been clear from the outside on
this the concrete action is that they
commit to insulate the houses of britain
to a zero carbon standard within the
next eight to ten years so that it's
done by 30 20 30 and we then have a
stroke
deal with all pure fuel poverty in this
country we deal with eight to forty
thousand people dying from cold every
winter we deal with fifteen percent of
the co2 output of this country at a
stroke that is a concrete action that
needs that they need to commit to now
and as soon as they commit to it to it
we are off the roads
right so in other words simply saying on
a target that they agree with you
that'll be enough to stop it because
that's not actually a concrete action is
it that's just saying that's what we
would like
no it's not a target is it they have to
actually come forward with concrete
policies for achieving this and it's not
an easy thing don't i mean we're not
under any illusions that this is an easy
thing to do if boris johnson were to
take leadership on this matter and carry
out this action that we are
suggesting that they do then he would be
all right revolutionizing uh world
politics he would be standing up as a
leader of the world in showing how the
uk can move forward on this issue i mean
after all the uk invented the industrial
revolution we invented carbon emissions
in the first place we led the world on
that so we should now lead the world out
of it
yeah but just give me one
practical suggestion to achieve your
ends that you want the government to
adopt that they're not adopting at the
moment
okay so to be a little bit more concrete
about it if they're going to insulate
the houses of britain in the next eight
to ten years then they need to commit
some very very substantial amounts of
money to that it's all about money isn't
it that's the bottom line so we would
want to see a commitment in monetary
terms and not kind of three three to six
billion which is what they've been
talking about we're talking about very
very substantial amounts of money to
achieve this uh which is why it would be
a world leadership act to do it
and so how much if it's not three to six
billion how much
how much i reckon it would cost and i'm
an architect so i know about what things
cost in the construction industry i
reckon this would cost between half a
trillion and one trillion pounds let's
say three quarters of a trillion pounds
for the sake of argument um that is an
absolutely immense amount of money uh
it's about five percent of gdp
uh per year i think some sort of that
sort of order of uh order amount of
money but then when you compare that
with something like quantitative easing
it's less than quantitative easing cost
and what did quantitative easing do
after the financial crisis all it did
was inflate the asset prices of the
wealthy people what we're talking about
is a concrete policy to not inflate
asset prices but to improve the concrete
lives and the concrete homes of the
ordinary people of this country that's
what that policy would do
okay it's quite a hefty tax bill thank
you very much indeed for that